españa sigue caminando hacia la igualdad
tras casi dos años desde que se diera
luz verde al anteproyecto este jueves el
congreso de los diputados de la nación
ibérica aprobó por amplia mayoría la ley
orgánica de garantías integral de la
libertad sexual conocida como ley del
solo si es y un paso adelante en los
derechos de las mujeres y una victoria
de la apuesta de la ministra de igualdad
irene montero abro a la ley de libertad
sexual con 205 votos a favor gracias a
la mayoría parlamentaria feminista que
lo ha hecho posible la legislación
aprobada pone el foco en el
consentimiento explícito de las mujeres
a la hora de mantener relaciones
sexuales hasta ahora sólo se consideraba
violación cuando se podía probar la
fuerza o la intimidación pero con esta
nueva lectura penal el texto hecho por
tierra el delito de abuso sexual y
modifica las penas por violación con
hasta 15 años de prisión además ofreció
mayor protección a las víctimas con
especial énfasis en menores de edad este
cambio de paradigma nació a raíz de una
brutal violación grupal que se acudió a
españa en el verano de 2016 el caso
conocido como la manada aquí es que esta
ley supone un cambio de paradigma un
cambio completo de paradigma si no hay
consentimiento explícito por parte de
las mujeres lo que se está produciendo
es una agresión así y así declaró
señorías estrechamos así el margen para
las interpretaciones machistas que se
hacen sobre el comportamiento de las
mujeres se acabó aquello de que
llevábamos la falda muy corta o si
cerramos o no las piernas se acabó la
nueva ley fue eso sí aprobada pese a la
negativa de los partidos más a la
derecha del parlamento los conservadores
del partido popular y los
ultraderechistas de box que la tacharon
de infame porque el objetivo de es
proteger a la mujer es destruir al
hombre eso sí al hombre blanco
heterosexual porque después la ley de
violencia de género esta es la ley más
racista y homófoba y sexista que hay
pese a las polémicas y los retrasos la
ley de sólo si es y es ya una realidad